[Music]
not today's earn your favorite Disney
movies almost started and ended in very
different ways
keep watching to the end to discover
which alternate opening idea didn't go
to waste because it got used in the
movie sequel Mulan opening were so
excited for the live-action remake of
move on with Briana toss but did you
know the original animated feature could
have had a very different beginning the
opening that made the final cut features
the terrifying villain Shan Yu and his
hun army invading China but the movie
makers drew up a storyboard for an
alternate opening scene in the magical
[Music]
it features Milan's daydream about
defeating Shamu saving China and being
rewarded by the Emperor um spoiler alert
/ glad Disney didn't give away the
entire plot The Lion King ending The
Lion King is another Disney animated
feature that has been giving a remake at
routines such as for what he didn't do
the 2019 version faithfully tracks the
plot of the original however the 1994
original could have turned out quite a
bit darker if this alternate ending had
made the final cut an early concept for
the fight scene had Simba show mercy to
scar up on Pride Rock
only to have scar kick him over the edge
scar was so busy celebrating with an
evil laugh that he didn't notice the
flames that engulfed him we then cut to
a shot of Simba alive and well if a
little scorched nuzzling a lioness in
the actual movie of course scar met his
end at the paws of the hyenas Nova star
which was inspired by an alternate
ending for another movie Beauty and the
Beast ending in the 1991 animated movie
Beauty and the Beast
we watched Gaston plummet into the
ravine after battling the beast on the
castle tower but in an alternate
versions Gaston and beast battled in a
forest Belle hit Gaston with a rock and
he fell off the cliff
wolves then set upon him that version
was deemed too gruesome but it was later
reworked for the 1994 movie The Lion
King with hyenas instead of wolves sword
in the stone opening the 50th
anniversary blu-ray release up sword in
the stone revealed an alternate opening
to the 1963 movie
the opening that made the final cut
showed wart in the woods on a hunting
trip with Kay wart goes looking for
Kay's lost arrow and comes across
Merlin's cottage the alternate opening
however is much more sinister the
villainous madam MIM sends her Raven to
find Prince Arthur I'm being take over
people me and the bird catches an arrow
that wart shoots the Raven draws wart
deep into the dangerous wood for madam
MIM in the Black Knight to capture
fortunately Merlin rescues him whew
The Incredibles opening director Brad
Bird originally planned to start The
Incredibles by introducing Bob and Helen
Parr as regular people we are now
officially moved in he even wanted to
gradually reveal that they're
superheroes so in this alternate opening
we see the couple meeting their
neighbors at a barbecue Helen gets into
a debate defending her motherhood
against the corporate world you consider
raising a family nothing this distracts
Bob to the point that he smacks a knife
down on his fingers of course he doesn't
injure himself but he has to pretend
that he did to keep his cover it's a
funny scene and we kind of wish they'd
gone with this version Robin Hood ending
just like in the actual ending we see
Robin Hood jump off a castle to escape
capture in the alternate version
[Applause]
where it differs though is that Robin
gets injured Little John takes him to a
cottage and Maid Marian helps but Prince
John sneaks up on them with a plan to
finish them off and in crucem way
fortunately King Richard saves a day
what a relief
Zootopia opening the alternate opening
for Zootopia still features a young Judy
and her friends putting on a show but
rather than Judy's parents lecturing her
about the restrictions of what she can
be its her teacher instead I'm saying
that what you want to be should be
realistic the version that made the
final cut is also more dramatic because
Judy gets hurt but still goes ahead with
her heroic act to save Bobby Treasure
Planet ending the 2002 movie Treasure
Planet isn't as well known as the other
films on this list but it's got a cult
following - the best part and it's also
got an alternate ending in the alternate
version Jim Hawkins still meets up with
his mother but this version is a lot
simpler than the one that made the final
cut Jim and his mom rebuild the end
together and that's it his sure is a
feel-good ending but not nearly as
interesting as the official ending in
the actual movie Jim joined the
interstellar Academy as a military
cadets The Little Mermaid ending the
ending of The Little Mermaid that we all
know features Ursula growing to gigantic
proportions
Eric finally defeats her by driving the
ship's sharp point into her huge body
however it could have played out
differently you'll be glad to hear the
sea witch is still defeated but it's
more of a team effort the co-director
John Musker shared an alternate version
of the climax of the movie where the
battle scene involves Sebastian Arielle
and flounder - instead of a big ship
Eric only has a tiny rowboat and
Sebastian helps Eric by passing him the
Trident to attack Ursula with Toy Story
opening Toy Story has lots of alternate
scenes including a different opening -
the first movie in the franchise rather
than being all about woody which is the
version that made the cut okay this
alternate opening zoomed in on Buzz
Lightyear instead he's shown defeating
Zerg it's totally interesting because
the idea of a face-off between Buzz and
Dirk got reused as the opening for Toy
Story 2 so that's a wrap on 10 alternate
beginnings and endings to your favorite
Disney movies which ones do you prefer
in the final cut let us know in the
comments make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you soon
[Music]